this is naked woman destroys outback
[Music]
this breaks my heart man first of all
first of all lady you in here we just
got restaurants
open lady
we just got them open
and you know how hard it is to get
anything imported right now
huh and you out here at outback
okay you out here at the australian
uh what is it called center of
teamwork um you're out here at the
australian consulate
in wherever this is buffalo new york
and you can't handle yourself
this is why we can't have nice things
look at her
oh and she's naked look at this
you don't bring a bloomin onion to a
bloomin onion
honey okay good
christ
[Music]
oh and the guy asked he said look
this is the worst part about having to
work at a corporate thing
he goes ma'am please
and she don't get it she don't get it
little tiffany can't tighten up
for one minute she's out here showing
that slick wallet to everybody
at the dang outback
my favorite part there's a woman waiting
in the distance there's a woman
there's a woman waiting to be seated
still in the foyer
she's gonna stay and ride it out she's
like you know i drove over here i'ma
still see if they can get me in
[Music]
oh and you can see a little bit of booty
right there damn boy
oh
now here comes the officer baby let's go
oh yeah
oh this is like csi australia dude this
is it
she's throwing stuff at this cop what
and i want to apologize to australia man
we
you know we better than this one we
better
than this
she just told the cop when i'm at a club
that she is treated a certain type of
way
well [__] this is australia
okay and your little woke ass about to
go to sleep
he's sucking
on your stomach you're gonna get again
and he he freaking he lit her up baby
that's that december 25th baby he gave
her that freaking
that pistol christmas daddy you feel me
she got tased up
you could see her just hit them
kookaburra wings dog
whoo that's what you get that's what you
get ladies when your dad
doesn't uh you know kind of teach you
how to do stuff properly
and right there and that's probably
addiction right there as well
but shout out australia man we love you
guys and um
you know with that's not us that's that
[__]
and uh we ain't her so
i love you guys and i can't wait to get
back over to australia and i'm sorry
about everything with that lady
dang boy he gave her that signature
sampler boy and
she broke all that dish where we just
got
restaurants open and this is what you do
i hope they spray that broad down with
covid
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one